[Music]
[Applause]
why does the zebra look the way it does
so embarrassing hey Focus say home one
no it's different
now you've been on my mind recently
because you keep popping up in my dreams
you don't do anything you're just there
so this specific
person the remarkable nobody I'm also
not that experience do you have a
picture have you been dreaming about me
have I been dreaming about you
yeah there's like a 100 messages
somebody wants to interview me this is
strange maybe you should take a minute
and think before you do anything
drastic why me uh I don't know I'm
special I guess
how does it feel to go viral who's
actually had a dream about
[Music]
me you're scaring me P I'm going to have
nightm I wish I was the one people were
dreaming about me too yeah no it's it's
something how's he dealing with all this
we're not even the type of people that
like attention you know do you think
other people are seeing you naked maybe
thousand
I hope I'm behaving your dreams Oh no
you're not so I'm finally cool huh I
didn't say that you hear that Janet
she's saying I'm a cool
dad really feel like you're playing with
fire
here Dad please help me I'm not actually
doing anything to
them you know Fame can come with some
less desirable side effects you should
be prepared for that maybe we should
cool this thing off what what do you
mean it's embarrassing which
part
you're I guess I'll uh guess I'll see
you my dreams yeah of course
[Music]
not